this is the greatest advance in modern  physics since the splitting of the atom  a rare metal molecularly unstable it's  what they're made of  break it up all the way you guys have  never seen a truck like this before  dad he keeps spending money on junk I  don't think it's a truck at all I think  we just found a transformer I'm gonna  ask you this once where is Optimus Prime  after all we have done  humans are hunting us but I fear we are  all targets now what is that  you said you here  this is not war  it's human extinction  more of my kind must be sacrificed  that half a prime maybe not who we are  and we can be  I'm not leaving my death  we need a new army  you